today we are we going to work on is this
line of best fit the game but in the
past always look that is I just go back
to the graph if the pause all we've done
is say yeah look there is your data
right and the line of best fit should be
soldered roughly through there I just
asked you to draw one in and you just
did it by eye okay if all you've got is
the picture then all you can do is do it
by life however we have the done so you
can actually calculate the line as best
it not a you learn invest it there is
actually a way to calculate the line
that goes through and fix the best and
that is called I'm going to write on
here I you might want write it down your
book it is a clause now you want either
will do work on the computer it's called
the least squares line of best bit
offended again the least squares as in
le ASP least squares line effective so
now let me explain what this is we
already have a rough idea of what the
line of best fit is it's a line that
roughly speaking is going to go sort of
through the middle of your data
something like that okay so if you are
asked to do this by high I can go to be
fairly okay maybe actually I'll move it
down just a teeny bit something like
yeah that's pretty good
you can see how I did that by eye
because you learn is that exactly one
data point that's on my line of best fit
how many are above two and how many are
below not a hundred percent you know
guaranteed but that's a pretty good way
to know at least we do this when we're
marketing it is a decent line of best
fit it's the same number of bars as
below are they roughly the tennis now so
this is approximate but lauda actually
work out one unique line of best is how
do we actually measure it how do we
quantify it
here's what we do and if you go back to
when you drawn some lines of best fit on
to Donna maybe you want to add this in
the better the line of best fit is right
the closer it will be to all these data
points here you see all my red lines
there are the distances from your data
points to your line of best fit now what
you want is for all of those distances
to be the small as possible okay
however you also want not just the
minimum distance but you also want some
above and some below okay now this is
actually quite tricky because when you
think about say let's go in orange when
you think about these distances here
they're below and you want to take into
account the fact that they are below and
not above okay so you would actually say
it will be the negative these guys over
here right then below the line of best
fit whereas these guys on top are
positive okay so we want this to balance
out but the same time I want the
smallest number okay so instead of
saying the smallest number that would
just be as negative as possible because
maybe your numbers are all smaller than
positive numbers what we say instead is
I want the smallest squares let me draw
it for you and I'll show you what I mean
I draw some squares on to you sorts of
them this say if I draw some squares on
to here I wonder if you can see how this
solves the problem of positives and
negatives right if you square a number
regardless of whether is positive or
negative in line you'll get a positive
and if we can make that as small as
possible if I can make all of these
squares the smallest possible then that
means my line of best it would be really
really good okay now that process of
actually doing that is quite complicated
your calculator will help you with a lot
of it we're going to need the
correlation coefficient and we're going
to need to know the mean of each of the
X values which is a cross and Y values
that process is quite tricky
which is why I've given you your
references or the dungeon
can you look at the side which is copied
in a4 rather than the size of chopped
into a five off the side is copied in a4
I want you to look at the bottom
right-hand side and you'll see there it
says least squares line of best fit so
you are going to be expected to do this
let me show you what I mean let's run
around we are doing remember that X
equation we called this data a lot right
so this is what I showed you the first
thing I said was whoops is we're going
to have to use our calculator press the
buttons put all that data in and we're
going to have to verify this zero point
nine zeroes ever whatever it was okay
you've got to do that but now if I
scroll just a little bit it is by using
the appropriate fully from the Fourier
data sheet and the given information you
know all that data determine the
equation of the least squared line of
best fit okay now I wonder if you look
at that you think wow okay why have they
made this so this question so long I'll
tell you why your calculator can
actually determine the line of best fit
pretty much automatically just like it
does to a correlation coefficient okay
so I'm going to suggest and I'm going to
show you how to do that
I'm going to suggest you use that as
kind of like a I can check my answer I
can know whether I got it right or not
okay
however as this question suggests the
wording of it
also the fact that it's how many marks
right and look at how many lines of
working you've got there they're
expecting you they want you to know how
to do this so I'm going to walk you
through it okay now to prepare us for
this I want you to just look at the arm
at the scuffle deformed shape and how
much stuff has to go into it you're
going to need the gradient we're going
to calculate out a visit you get the our
or diner down the correlation
coefficient so this will work that out
but we're going to be the standard
deviation of the Y scores how you do
that
with this again okay I'll give me the
standard deviation of the X scores which
means this again and then you've got to
lastly x bar and y bar they even tell
you what those are
there that means for each of the x my
bows how are you going to do that okay
so there's lots of pieces that go into
this I'm going to walk you through it
but what we do you have to have is not
just this information and your scatter
plot I also like you to punch back this
information into your bivariate data
mode on your calculator so I'm since put
all kinds of other data in there so I'm
going to quickly redo that and then
we're going to have a got this together
so just as a bit of a refresher in case
you're like I missed the period or you
can't remember I'm going to make sure
everything is cleared out I already do
that a bit paranoid I'm going to go and
burn stat which one of these do I pick
against two to satisfy very okay the
exes of the Phoenix and the Y's are the
chemistry so I'm going to go ahead and
just push all those numbers let's have a
got this together yeah this is going to
be a little bit tricky because you're
kind of going to need your eyes in three
places at the same time okay you're
going to need to use this kind of like
as your recipe list your guide okay all
of the things you need to put into here
you're going to need to get off here
right and then thirdly you actually show
just like I showed you on that HSC
question you're going to need to show
those working that puts all of these
things together okay so here's the way
I'm going to suggest that we walk
through this on your page and I'm going
to go back to that on your page we're
going to say okay what I'm working out
is line of best fit so that's the first
thing we're going to write down just so
that all of these equations are numbers
that we can write down in a minute
aren't in a vaccine you mind explaining
what I do the line of best fit is the
first thing that you see underneath the
heading on the phone in entirety why
important
the gradient times X plus y intercept
now we've got this 19 a.m. 3 I think
we'll get straight lines that's the long
way of saying turn over the other side
of your formula done sheet again look at
the very bottom right-hand corner you
see it says this you recognize that
right so this this now you can come back
to the line of best fit is exactly what
the first line says y equals gradient
times X plus y intercepts so they're
just explaining what this is all right I
need to work out the two pieces that go
in here can you see on the for the data
sheet it says gradients equals and then
there's a bunch of stuff and then it
also says why does have equals and then
there's a bunch of stuff so that's
what's going to go into each of these
things that's gradient and that is
y-intercept
okay so let's go ahead and work out you
go
one line down on the for this data sheet
it says gradient equals okay now I want
you to look carefully what that's got on
the phones I sheet I'm going to switch
over to my calculator now and we're
going to work this out is my calculator
all my data is there Oh see that times
about how that okay yep this vocal
inflection I'm going to clear it out so
that I can now go into you know putting
you requesting whatever data I want the
bobbin is Donna she tells me I need to
put in three things I need R so I'm
going to go shift one where am I going
to go to find that correlation
coefficient five by the way re G refers
to one of the names of the line of best
fit that I mentioned before line of best
fit trend line it's also called the
regression line regression line that's
what re G stands for in fact maybe on
your piece of paper you want to note
down next to where you wrote line up
that's it and neither of the names is
line of regression or regression lines
so I'm going to get fired which ones I
want three will give me ah
okay that's the correlation coefficient
but that's not actually the whole thing
that I need go back to your formulas
datasheet what am I going to multiply by
have a look at the footage datasheet
what to say for the top of that fraction
standard deviation of the Y scores okay
so I'm going to go again
I want to find where is the standard
deviation okay do you remember whether
standing we went with constant deviation
so standard deviation hmm is it no
that's what that's that's quartile
that's core fun go back ships well gonna
go back ah there's our I actually think
in oh so far okay now before you've seen
some of these before for instance see
that guy there
I know it's hard to really calculate
abductive Sigma right that standard
deviation before all we saw with Sigma X
but now there's extra things here why
they're extra things by variedad all
right so now you can see there's a
standard deviation for Y and the
standard deviations X which ones I would
first why why then all the six that's on
the top and then on the bottom we're
going to divide by the standard
deviation of X of Sigma X so I'm going
to shift 103 yeah you got it yeah so
this is what my calculator display shows
now when I hit equals it should give me
what the formative data sheet says is
the gradient okay are you ready for me
to pretty close that's why I'm good
got the number yes so go back your piece
of paper down go back your piece of
paper and I would write down that number